Transcriber: Emre Incel
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Plak dinleyeniniz var mı?
Plak, plak, plak meraklıları,
plak dinleyenler, plak alanlar.
Bakayım, bakayım, evet, eller, herkes
kaldırsın, oralarda da var.
Peki şimdi çok dürüst bir şey soracağım
ama lütfen hakikaten dürüst cevap verin.
Dinliyor musunuz?
Plağa meraklı olup, plağı alıyor musunuz?
Peki meraklı olup, böyle bir heves alıp da
evinde orada böyle rafta tutanlar var mı?
Var.
Şimdi the Economist'te, bundan galiba
1-2 hafta önceydi bir haber çarptı gözüme.
Geçen yıl, 2015'te bütün dünyada
plak satışları inanılmaz artmış,
on iki milyon plak satılmıştı.
On iki milyon çok büyük
gelmeyebilir ama bu rakam
1988'den bu yana en büyük rakammış.
Gerekçeyi araştırmış, niye böyle oldu
diye Ekonomist ve şuna varmış.
1950'lerde, 60'larda geçen ve bütün
dünyayı saran dizilerin nostalji etkisi.
Onun ateşlediği bir fitil olarak görülmüş.
Peki niye? Yani bir sesin
o long play sesi'nin peşinden gitmek
Çok nostaljik gelebiliyor,
ama haberin dramı burada bitmiyor.
Ekonomist sormuş:
"Peki aldığınız plakları
dinliyor musunuz?" diye.
Çoğu yanıt hayır.
İnsanların evinde pikap bile yok.
Pikap olanlar da dinlemiyor.
"Peki niye dinlemiyorsunuz?"
diye sormuş.
Cevap:"Tozlanıyorlar,
toz almak istemiyoruz."
Şimdi, o nostaljiye sahip olmak.
Bugünün galiba dünyasını
açıklayan iki kelime:
Sahip olmak.
Sahip oluyor ama onun gereklerini
yerine getirmiyor, onu hayata geçirmiyor.
Oysa bin dokuz yüz mesela
60'larda, 50'lerde o plakların,
o sahibinin sesi, his masters voice
olduğu yıllarda böyle miydi?
O Beatles'ları hayal edin mesela.
Bir dizenin peşinden
bütün dünyayı sürükleyen grupları düşünün.
Daha adil, daha iyi gelir dağılımı için,
dünyanın kalkınabilmesi
ve bütün insanlığın
herkesin ulaştığı şeylere ulaşabilmesi
için verilen çabayı düşünün.
Sokağa dökülen insanları düşünün.
Mesela, Bob Dylan'ı düşünün.
(Müzik: Bob Dylan - Blowin' in the Wind)
Daha kaç kulak gerekecek diyor,
daha kaç can gidecek diyor.
Bugünden çok farklı değil
ama o zaman sokaklardaydık.
İlla yaşamış olmamız gerekmiyor.
Burada çok gençler var.
Yaşamak öyle bir şey değil zaten.
Hücrelerimiz oralarda dolaştı,
bir şekilde kodlarımız var.
70'lere gelindiğinde,
60'ların karşıt kültür denilen hareketi
daha da coştu.
Yani o çiçek çocuklar belki
70'lerin başından itibaren daha zayıfladı.
Ama İstanbul'dan Kalküta'ya,
bilenler bilir, dolmuşlar kalkıyordu,
otobüsler kalkıyordu.
İnsanlar, bir idealin peşinden
sürükleniyordu ve yine sokaklardalardı.
Fakat 70'ler biraz daha
farklı yıllardı 60'lardan.
Çünkü Batı, kadın hareketleri, özgürlük,
içindekini doğru ifade edebilme
ve özgür olabilme temeli üzerinden
yeni haklar kazanırken,
Doğu, başta İran olmak üzere
dine bulaşmış ve din ülkeleri kuruluyordu.
Bütün bunlar olurken
petrol üreticisi ülkelerin
petrol fiyatlarını
yükseltmeleri ile beraber
bütün dünyada ciddi
krizler ve çatlaklar oluşmaya başladı.
Para artık daha önemli bir materyaldi
ve krizler arka arkaya geliyordu.
(Müzik:
Pink Floyd - Another Brick In The Wall)
Eğitime ihtiyacımız yok diyor
ama bizim vardı Türkiye olarak.
Fakat komünist-faşist
çatışmasından dolayı okula gidemiyorduk.
Okullarımızın çoğu eğitim veremiyordu.
Bir taraftan da-
Bu arada bir şey geldi aklıma.
Adidas'ı olan var mı şu anda ayağında?
Ayağında Adidas olanlar var mı?
El kaldırsınlar.
Sizin o ayağınızdakiler
benim çocukluğumun en büyük hayaliydi.
Biz o zaman yurt dışından biri bize
Adidas getirsin diye
her şeyi vermeye hazırdık.
O kadar yoktu, o kadar yoktu.
Çok şanslısınız, şimdi tabii
her şeye ulaşabiliyoruz
ama bu aslında bir lanet,
birazdan geleceğiz.
O yıllarda, evet biz kuyruklarda,
mesela annem beni kulağımdan tuta tuta
kuyruklara götürürdü.
Aygaz kuyruklarında,
Sana yağ kuyruklarında geçti hayatım.
Çocuk olmak böyle aslında
acınası bir durum.
Çünkü evde getir götür
işlerine siz bakarsınız.
Fakat, o çocukluğun keşke
tadını bileydik diyoruz şimdi.
Çünkü bir sabah, sabaha karşı
bir sesle uyandık
ve bir daha hiç küçülmemek üzere büyüdük.
"Silahlı Kuvvetler, aziz Türk milletinin
hakkı olan refah ve mutluluğu,
vatan ve milletin bütünlüğü
ve gittikçe etkisi azalmaya,
azaltılmaya çalışılan Atatürk ilkelerine
yeniden güç ve işlerlik kazandırmak,
kendi kendini
kontrol edemeyen demokrasiyi
sağlam temeller üzerine oturtmak,
kaybolan devlet otoritesini
yeniden tesis etmek için
yönetime el koymak zorunda kalmıştır."
Bir daha hiçbir şey eskisi gibi olmadı.
Çünkü hakikaten bir anda büyüdük.
Özgürlük denen bir şey
o anda anlayacağımız bir şey değildi.
Çünkü biz özgürlükten sokağa çıkma
yasakları dışındaki anları anlıyorduk.
Gerçekten, zaten bir şeye ulaşamıyorduk
ve kafamızın, hele de YÖK çocukları olarak
hikmeti kendinden menkul eğitim
anlayışını daha idrak edememiştik.
Tek bildiğimiz şuydu, sokaklar sakin.
Derken üç yıl sonra
bir adam çıktı, geldi hayatımıza.
Biz hiçbir şey bilmezken,
bir Adidas için bile çok şeyi
feda edebilecekken,
dedi ki bize
"Vitrinler de serbest, insanlar da.",
dedi ki "Benim memurum işini bilir."
"Eşeğin kuyruğunu kalabalıkta kesme."
diye bir atasözümüz vardır.
Çünkü kimi kısa kesiyorsun dermiş,
kimi de uzun kesiyorsun.
Elbette ki her konuda herkesi aynı
şekilde memnun etmek mümkün değildir.
Gördüğünüz gibi ehliyet almak kolaylaştı
diye seviniyor, kimi de kızıyor.
İş yapmak için kaynak yaratıyoruz.
Dışarıdan kredi alıyoruz.
Borç kime verilir?
Ödeyebilecek olana.
Yoksa kimse kimseye karşılıksız
günahını bile vermez."
İşte bu cümle hayatımızın
kilit noktasına oturdu.
Kimse kimseye karşılıksız
günahını bile vermez.
Karşılık, karşılıksız hiçbir şey yapmamak,
her şeyin karşılığını beklemek.
Artık dokumuz değişmeye başlamıştı.
Mayamız pütürlenmeye başlamıştı.
Türk insanı, o neoliberal denen,
dünyayı da elinin altına alan,
düzenin içinde evrilmeye, değişmeye,
dönüşmeye başlamıştı.
70'lerde mütevazıydık.
Yağ satardık, bal satardık.
İstikrarlıydık, ustamız ölünce
biz satardık.
80'lere geldikten sonra
orta direk dediği Özal'ın adına,
yeni bir oluşum oluştu
ve bizim gibi
orta gelir sınıfındaki insanların
üzerine ekonomi
bina edilirmiş gibi yapıldı.
Fakat balayı kısa sürdü
ve 90'lara gelindiğinde orta direk çöktü.
Artık ya fakir çok fakirdi
ya da zengin çok daha zengindi.
Başka bir anlayış içindeydi Türkiye.
Tıpkı dünyayla beraber.
Ama bir taraftan da kan gölüne dönmüştü.
Hem ülkede terör yükselmişti, hem de
dışarıda Birinci Irak Savaşı yaşanıyor,
Balkanlar parçalanıyor,
her yerden kan kokusu geliyordu.
Böyle bir dönemdi.
Şimdi size bir bilmece soracağım.
60'larda, 70'lerde,
eşit gelir dağılımı için,
Afrika'da yaşayan açlar için,
üç sokak ötesi için sokağa dökülen dünyalı
ne oldu da 90'lardan sonra
kendinden başka
hiçbir şey düşünemez oldu?
Nerde bu insanlar?
Niye sokakta kimse yok?
Bir ekonomik icat
bizim bütün sorgulamalarımızı öldürdü.
Nedir bu icat diye soracağım.
Var mı cevap?
(Seyirci cevap veriyor)
Evet, kredi kartı.
Şu kart.
90'ların ekonomisi, kredi kartı, internet
ve cep telefonu üzerine kuruldu.
Bu iki küçük alet
bizim bütün beynimizin hücrelerini,
sorgulamalarımızı, insanlığımızı
kendi bünyelerine hapsetti.
Kredi kartı, cep telefonu
ve internet ile beraber,
dünya ve Türk insanı dönüşmeye başladı.
Ardından 2000'ler geldi.
2000'lerde de üçlü sac ayağı vardı.
Türkiye için AVM, inşaat ve finans.
Aslında AVM'lerin,
yani beyin hücrelerimizdeki oksijenlerin
yavaş yavaş öleceğinin sinyalleri
90'ların sonu 2000'lerin başında
verilmeye başlamıştı.
Nerden biliyor musunuz?
O balkonunda oturan, mangal yakan,
çekirdek çitleyen,
televizyon izleyen Türk insanı,
balkonlarını kapatmaya başladı.
Önce evler büyüdü.
2 kişi, 3 kişi iki yüz
metrekareye sığamaz oldu.
Banyo sayıları arttı.
Sonra giysi odaları eklendi.
Yetmedi, balkonları camla çevirdik.
Artık oksijenimiz çok azdı.
AVM'ler geldi.
Arabamıza biniyor, kapalı otoparka
giriyor, asansörden çıkıyor
ve içerde çocuk oyun alanında,
restoranda, sinemada, alışverişte
onların bize sunduğu oksijenle
ne üşüyorduk ne de terliyor.
Böyle bir anlayışla giderek
oksijenle temasımız azaldı.
Derken zaten üstüne bir de 2010'lardan
sonra Gezi gelip biber gazını yiyince
oksijenle temasımız tümden kesildi.
(Alkış)
Peki, niye buradasınız?
Niye buradayız?
Yeni fikirler duymak için mi?
Yeni vizyonlar tanımak için mi?
Uzayı, Cern'ü, atomu, Gezi'yi,
şunu, bunu anlamak için mi?
Eğer buradan çıkıp, taksiti bitmemiş
arabanıza binip,
kapalı otoparktan
alışveriş merkezine gideceksek,
eğer pazartesi günü
sevmediğimiz patronumuza,
sırf kredi borcumuzu
taksitlendirdik diye
ya da ev kredimizi ödemeyeceğiz diye
boyun eğeceksek,
ne anlamı var,
yeni fikirlerin ya da uzaya çıkmanın?
Şu küçücük kart-
(Alkış)
Şu küçücük kartın içinde
bütün dünyanın açlığı var.
Şu küçücük kartın içinde,
şu anda Somali'de bile
bu karttan veriyorlar açlara
biliyor musunuz?
Somali'de bile ellerine tutuşturuyorlar,
gidip Birleşmiş Milletler'den
yemek alabilsinler diye
ve bunu bu kartın sahibi yapıyor.
Biz sırf bunun borçları
için kredi çekiyoruz bu memlekette.
Bunun borcunu ödeyebilmek için
bankalardan kredi çekiyoruz.
Tasarruf oranımız
bu memlekette %14 arkadaşlar.
Geçtim gelişmişini, gelişmekte olan
ülkelerin bilegerisindeyiz,
ki biz de gelişmekte olan ülkeyiz.
Neyimize yetmiyor hiçbir şey?
Niye beşinci çanta, onuncu ayakkabı,
yirminci pantolon, otuzuncu gömlek?
Hangi giysi odası bizim içimizi doyuracak?
Hangi kapanmış balkonlar
bize insanlığımızı yeniden hatırlatacak?
Birer birer ölüyoruz.
Şu var ya, şu-
(Alkış)
Hani plaklar vardı ya,
alıp da dinlemediğimiz.
Sahibinin sesi, his masters voice
deniyordu ya onlara.
Tek bir sahibinin sesi var bugün.
Kilometrelerce öteden,
metrelerce öteden, bütün kalabalıkta,
Cumhurbaşkanı konuşurken,
Başbakan konuşurken,
Muhalefet konuşurken,
Tanklar, toplar, tüfekler konuşurken,
üstümüzden F-16'lar geçerken.
Her koşulda duyduğumuz tek bir ses var.
(Cep telefonu zil sesleri)
(Alkış)
Oysa, tek bir sesi duymak yeterli.
Bırakın hepsini gerçekten.
Size "Pantolon boyun kısa,
daha uzunu bu yıl moda.
Biraz daha bol pantolonlar lazım.
Hadi ya bu ev çok küçük
birazcık daha büyük eve çıkalım.
Yok yok, arabayı sen yenile."
diyen sesleri değil,
tek bir sesi duymamız lazım.
Tıpkı 93 yıl önce bugün,
Bu Cumhuriyet'i kuran adamın,
o sesi duyarak çıktığı yol gibi.
Tek bir ses bizi
birbirimizin içinden geçirecek.
Benim harcadığım şu paraların
aslında bir başka yerdeki
ağaçları kestiğini,
bir yerdeki suları bitirdiğini,
bir yerde atık oluşturduğunu anlamamızı
tek bir ses sağlayacak.
Bizim birbirimizin içinden geçtiğimizi,
bir zincir olduğumuzu,
ben burada gülerken, senin orada
ağlamanın mümkün olamayacağını,
sen ağlarken benim gülemeyeceğimi,
anlamamızın tek bir yolu olacak.
Tek bir ses bizi gerçekten
insanlığa yeniden döndürecek.
Yoksa başka yolu yok.
Gerçekten ölüyoruz.
Tek bir ses.
(Kalp atış sesi)
(Alkış)